الاقتصاد الروسي اصبح بعيدا عن خسائر
فاتحه توقعها التكنوقرات الروس وانفسهم
المقربون منبوت وخبراء دوليون بسبب
العقوبات التي يفردها الغرب على موسكو هذا
ما كشفت عنه صحيفه
البريطانيه كشفت عن كواليس وسيناريوهاتن
دارت بين سيد الكرملين والتكنقراض قبل شهر
من شن الحرب ضد اوكرانيا لدراسه العقوبات
الغربيه المحتمله ابرز التكنوقرات الرئيس
التنفيذي لسوبر بنك الذي حذر الرئيس بوتين
من عواقبه وخيمه في حال مهاجمه اوكرانيا
وايضا محافظه البنك المركزي ابدت مخاوفها
من خلق الذعر في الاسواق الماليه وربما
عوده الاقتصاد الى الوراء لعقود التحذير
من الانخفاض الناتج المحلي بنسبه 30%
بالدولار في غضون عامين وجعل روسيا تكافل
العثور على الغذاء والدواء وليس التقنيات
المتقدمه مع استمرار العقوبات فيما فاجا
بوتين المتحدثين بطلبه عن حلول لمواجهه
العقوبات وربما تجاوزها
شنبوتين الحرب في فبراير 2022 وبات على
التكنوقراط اي يثبت موقفهم مع احتدامها
تقول الفاينايشنال تايمز ان صمتهم يشير
الى مساعده بوتين وقبولهم بالحرب التي
يعلنون سرا انهم يعارضونها
لكونك عضو في فريق بوتين يعني انك تشاركه
قيمه ومبادئه وانك مخلص له بشكل كبير ومع
استبعاد الدول الغربيه لروسيا من الاسواق
الماليه العالميه وسلاسل التوريد انطلق
دوره التكنوقراط لانقاذ الكرم من خلال
استخدام مهارات الاداره الاقتصاديه
البارعه بعيدا عن التنبؤات السابقه تخفيف
وطاه العقوبات الغربيه وتماسك الاقتصاد
الروسي خلال الحرب اضافه الى جعل الضرر
على الناتج المحلي الاجمالي الاعتمادي على
البدائل الجاهزه بعد حرمان عملي انظمه
البنوك والمدفوعات العالميه بسبب العقوبات
ووفقا لخبراء غربيين فان دعم التكنوقرات
للاقتصاد الروسي ليس مؤهلا للصمود على
المدى الطويل مع استمرار حربي اوكرانيا
واستنزاف الترسانه العسكريه الروسيه جاسم
محسن العربيه